there are of course the examples that
you open up and see in the newspaper
everyday like british petroleum and
goldman sachs and toyota those companies
are a warning flag to every other
business that's not doing the right
thing you know those businesses happen
to have gotten caught in the mess that
they've created they are not alone in
doing some terrible things but they're
unique in that they have gotten caught
if you go back in time and you think
about a company like Toyota several
years ago while they were running all of
these ads about the Prius and how
sustainable the prius is and how much
they cared about the planet and the
environment at the same time secretly
they were lobbying in California against
increased gas mileage standards so you
know on the one hand they wanted to
appear as this sustainable company wow
you know with the other hand that
they're actually fighting the changes
that are required to make the world more
sustainable for everyone else that is
the kind of duality that I see at too
many companies too many companies who
want to talk about I mean I remember I
remember for years ago General Motors
put up billboards all around New York
and the the country advertising the
vault car now the vole car was not being
made they had no idea if it was going to
be made they had no idea when it was
going to be made but that didn't stop
them from advertising a car that didn't
exist as a way to bolster their image as
a responsible business you know things
like that are destructive to your
reputation and many companies don't
understand that this new world that we
live in the the transparency that is
created by the internet raises the
stakes
or companies getting away with stuff
that they used to be able to get away
with transparency will be forced upon
you if you choose not to be transparent
yourself and you will get caught doing
the wrong thing whether you get caught
by your own employees whether you get
caught by a blogger whether you get
caught by NGO or the government you'll
get caught and businesses need to be
proactive in a disclosing the problems
that they have which they're scared to
do and committing to the path that
they're going to take two to make change
you know BP when you think about it has
had a series of of problems ah you might
say it was a gutsy thing for a company
who had you know 99 percent of what they
sell is petroleum to say we're going to
be beyond petroleum now when they made
that announcement I was rooting for them
to win but it was a pretty audacious
claim to make and clearly not a claim
they were willing to stick with because
shortly thereafter they started getting
out of the alternative energy business
and wasted hundreds of millions of
dollars claiming to be something that
they really were not ready to be but
then they had a terrible explosion at a
plant in Texas that killed some of their
workers then of course they've had this
tremendous spill in the Gulf of Mexico
there is a series of patterns which goes
back to the issue of what kind of
culture do we have what kind of culture
do we have that we ignore the questions
that must arise inside the company about
the the the the this intelligence to do
some of the things that we're doing that
to me is a sign of a culture where those
questions are repressed those questions
aren't answered and a handful of people
are allowed to continue to do the wrong
thing because they ignore the challenges
that are raised internally and i think
that the BP you know is a metaphor in a
lot of ways i mean i think about this
oil spill which is a very visible
representation of the way that we're
abusing the environment but it's really
no difficult different than the way we
handle chemicals we have an open spicket
through which millions of pounds of
toxic
chemicals are dumped into our society
into the air into the ground water
through our products it just happened to
be invisible the effects are still there
increased asthma rates increased cancer
rates and children but we have many oil
spills whether they're chemicals whether
they're petroleum and and this goes back
to the notion that we as a society and
particularly we as businesses have all
the warning signs of what's ahead you
know how many more spills do we need how
many more earthquakes do we need or
volcanoes or or hurricanes I mean the
earth in a sense is telling us you can't
keep doing this there is a price that is
going to be paid for your behavior
I don't know whether Tony Hayward has
children but if he does I bet he's
getting an earful from his children
about how embarrassing it is to go to
school every day as the child of the
president of BP we should not
underestimate the pressure that that
brings on CEO and senior management BP
today is not a company you want to tell
people you work for when you show up at
a party so so there is a part of this
social pressure that will come to bear
on the company but we also need to hold
the government accountable the
government has has has totally
historically not held these oil
companies accountable for their
responsibilities as we see with the
mineral mineral Management Agency we
need to support NGOs because often it is
pressure from groups like Greenpeace
which I'm a board member of that will
help tilt the scale look you know you
won't catch me buying gas at a BP
station probably for the rest of my life
and I think that it is this combination
of factors it's pressure from the
government pressure from the NGOs
pressure from their internal employees
as well as what we can do as individuals
you know you may think that in this day
and age writing letters and emails
doesn't make a difference it does I can
tell you is a business owner and manager
when someone writes a letter I know that
there's probably a hundred if not a
thousand people that feel the same way
that that person felt and that carries a
lot of weight it's not one letter or one
email it is a representation of hundreds
or thousands of people who feel the same
way
the challenge of of moving the
commitment to sustainability beyond
senior management is ultimately a
cultural challenge you have to send that
message you have to incentivize people
you know if you pay out bonuses based
upon increased sales and profits and not
sustainability initiatives where will
people put their attention on profits
and sales so you have to embed these
ideas and incentives within your culture
you have to reward people that are
sustainability leaders not just the
biggest sales people and so it is
ultimately a cultural challenge and you
need to design your culture to function
and be aligned with your sustainability
objectives which also means that
ultimately it has to be embedded in
corporate strategy the only way to be
really responsible and really
sustainable is if it's part of your
strategy as a company it can't exist in
a compartment it really doesn't work to
have a sustainability corporate
responsibility police person who ensures
that everybody else at the company is
responsible that sense of responsibility
has to live in everybody that works in
the company in every department in the
strategies and goals and objectives of
every department and every person
I have faith in consumers but will never
depend upon them to solve all the
challenges that they that we face I mean
yes the marketplace is important and
there are more and more consumers every
year buying green and sustainable
products that's a good thing but
consumers face some fundamental
challenges when I talk to young people
they constantly ask me why are the good
things expensive and the bad things
cheap we have created an economic
construct through rules and regulations
and tax codes that allows businesses to
escape from most of their negative
impact so if you're an automobile
manufacturer and you sell a car that
gets poor gas mileage and that poor gas
mileage creates a lot of air pollution
that translates into increased asthma
allergies cancer you as a manufacturer
bear no responsibility for those
negative impacts those negative impacts
are dumped onto society and we pay those
negative impacts as a society now I
think that if you're going to do bad
stuff if you're going to be a farmer and
use pesticides that pollute the
groundwater you should have to pay for
all those negative impacts and if that
was the case if traditional growers of
food paid the full cost of soil erosion
water pollution adverse health effects
on their farm workers because of
exposure to pesticides something quite
amazing would happen organic food would
cost half the price of what traditional
food would cost and we wouldn't ask
consumers to make a very difficult
decision which is do the right thing
make the right choice by the sustainable
product but don't get any financial
benefit for making that choice so
ultimately we have to change the system
we have to change the economic landscape
so that business and consumers are all
aligned and incentivized to make the
sustainable choice you shouldn't have to
pay extra to buy a hybrid car you
shouldn't pay extra to buy organic
clothing those products are better and
more sustainable and more responsible
for the planet and they should cost less